just living the [ __ ] present guys
[Music]
like I just think the best former
ventures is a good body so [ __ ] everyone
laughing all right
yeah just life just look beyond it yes
I'd be more amazing to cut back times
[Music]
nowadays with social media it's way more
intense I really love the whole blocking
thing on Instagram these days and I am
using it every second I love it I love
to take social media breaks like I'll
post things and try not to read the
comments because if I was posting
something about me I post something with
me like raising money for cancer
awareness and I got reamed for it so
it's like no matter what I do you're
going to have just haters so just know
that that's the way of the world and
just love yourself I'm an all-in person
it's like it's like honestly if you're
not all in I just feel like you're not
like I just don't care because I've been
in relationship that I wasn't all in and
I was like I'm just trying to be
discreet I'm really like I actually
didn't like you stop being so shady so I
was [ __ ] Shady there's 24 hours in
the day I got to do it and figure it out
but like the last week I've been really
bad but I chose a night club over the
gym and I'm kind of still doing cardio
dancing so you know [ __ ] you [ __ ] I
hate people say are you tired like suck
my dick like that's so rude
that really is
[Music]
are you a food sharer I am a food chef
Vito I'm very sherry in fact I like like
multiple appetizer I order I would
rather order like 12 things and just
have a bite of like everything me and
more is better than less I don't want to
be hungry I love food so more is more
yeah more [ __ ] [ __ ] with my food but
I'll share with you but like we're all
gonna dig in yeah you just Yolo you only
live once you can't worry about it yeah
we all look like idiots have you ever
seen Seinfeld
we're like Elaine like you just got to
be Elaine and don't wear like you
cranberry air balls to the walls I try
to not bring baggage from my leg I
really think I'm great to having closure
like you could only I'm living in the
present I can't dwell in the past and if
I do I'm not ready to be in a new
relationship so I try to really know
that I'm healed and then because it's
not fair it's not fair to yourself or to
the person you're dating take some shots
and just like figure it out we're all
about to throw in the towel I feel like
just that's life and take a [ __ ]
bubble bath after that